I saw this video this morning this is
like the first thing when I opened up
Twitter you know I try not to tweet over
the weekends open up Twitter this
morning this is like the first thing I
saw it's going viral right now this is a
video that somebody took at Disneyland
over the weekend uh this is the girl
this is where the girls go this I mean
it's so nuts this is the store at
Disneyland where the girls go to buy
dresses so they can dress up like
princesses while they're at Disneyland
tell me if you think something's a
little odd here
oh
my snake I won a fairy Godmother's
apprentices I'm here to shop you around
selection for the day
okay
you must understand first off this is
not a trans person that's a man in a
dress hence he still has a Mustang right
so that's a transvestite not a
transsexual that's not someone as far as
I can tell who's identifying as a woman
you wouldn't keep the must there so why
would you intentionally confuse these
children again that dude who is a dude
can do whatever he wants in the privacy
of his own life he could actually have
any job at Disneyland he could be in a
full costume he could be selling hot
dogs he could be a guy that's in charge
of the lines at the rides all of those
things but Disney made a choice oh at
the outside of the store where a bunch
of five to 12 year old girls are going
to walk in to get in dresses we will
have a man with a mustache wearing a
dress is that why anyone goes to Disney
to have their children confused again
this has nothing to do with bigotry or
racism or any anything else like that
but that is exactly why Disney must be
hit they made an intentional choice to
do that so imagine you're the average
guy
the average family man who has two kids
you have let's say you have a son and a
daughter you take them there to Disney
as you know if you were trying to go to
the Star Wars thing for a family of four
it was like five thousand bucks a night
so they just closed that or actually
they announce it'll be closing it closes
actually in October but it's a
tremendous failure just on the financial
level but then you go to Disney and your
daughter loves Little Mermaid and you
want to get her in a dress and now she's
six-year-old and then a guy with a
mustache is like come in come in and put
on a dress and now like it's just it's
just entered your daughter's mind this
confusion and that's what they want
everybody to be they want everybody to
be confused
[Music]
thank you